hey guys my name is vishwas and welcome
to a brand new tutorial series on
angular material in this introductory
video let's take a look at what is
angular material the prerequisites for
this course and also the course
structure alright let's begin what is
angular material angular material is a
UI component library what that means is
angular material provides us with
components to build awesome user
interfaces in QuickTime it is also an
implementation of Google's material
design specification just like how we
have material UI for react beautify for
view we have angular material for
angular the goal here is to learn how to
use the library components to build
clean and elegant UI now before we get
started let me quickly run you through
the prerequisites as always HTML CSS and
JavaScript go without saying in addition
to these you also need to have a
knowledge of angular you don't have to
be an expert by any means but some basic
knowledge is absolutely necessary if you
are feeling rusty make sure to go
through the angular tutorials on my
channel before starting this course now
as of this recording the current major
version of angular and angular material
is seven with new releases there might
be minor tweaks but what you will learn
in this series will still hold good so
you can watch this entire series without
any hesitation alright how are we going
to proceed with this course first we
will learn how to add angular material
to an angular application then we will
discuss about typography
in angular after that we will take a
look at the different components that
make up the library the components fall
under six major categories we have
buttons and indicators navigation layout
from controls
pop-ups and models and finally data
tables we will not take a detailed look
at every single one of them but we will
cover the important ones by the end of
this course you will have a good
understanding of how the individual
angular material components work you can
then use that knowledge to build angular
applications that suit your requirement
all right then let's get started in the
next video
in this video let's see how we can add
angular material to an angular
application now before I show you how to
do that I want to tell you that for this
course we will be closely looking at the
documentation and that is for two
reasons first one is to stay updated
with the changes there will be future
releases of angular material and it is
safe to rely on the documentation as it
is constantly updated the second reason
is to know the directives that have to
be used for the different components
when we start writing code we need to
import certain components and it is next
to impossible to know the component
names without referring to the
documentation so make sure you have a
tab open for the dogs while you are
following the videos alright with that
let's see how to add angular material to
an angular application from the navbar I
am going to navigate to the guides
section of the documentation here you
can see the getting started heading as
well as the schematics heading both
these sections contain information on
how to install angular material
depending on the version of your angular
application the getting started section
contains about six different steps which
you have to go through to set up
material in your angular application and
this is only if your project is below
version six for this series we will be
working with angular version seven so I
will demo how to add material with CLI
schematics which is valid for angular
version 6 and above now in the terminal
when I run the command ng - - version
you can see that I have angular CLI
version seven if you are at a lower
version please make sure to update it
before creating a new project alright
now what I have done is created a brand
new project using the command
engi new material - demo material - demo
is the name of the project we will be
working with and of course I have opened
the project folder in vias code next to
setup angular material
make sure you navigate into the project
folder and run the command ng had at
angular slash material when we run the
command it is going to ask us an option
for the team I'm going to stick with
indigo pink next it checks with us for
hammer jeaious for gesture recognition I
will simply go with yes for now next
browser animations again yes
and that is pretty much all you have to
do you are ready to start using angular
material in your application and this
was possible because angular material is
packaged with CLI schematics what that
means is that the angular team provided
us with a single command that will
handle setting up material in your
application let's take a look at the
differences to see what changes were
made by running the command first up
angular dot JSON the only difference is
the inclusion of a CSS file in the
Styles array and this is the indigo pink
theme which we opted for the next file
is package dot JSON here you can see
that angular cdk and angular material
have been added to the list of
dependencies next we also have updates
to the package lock dot JSON file and
then we have index dot HTML here two
references have been added one to
material icons and the other to Roboto
font
in mindo TS there is the inclusion of
ham urges in style.css there is some CSS
reset that has been added to the body
tag
finally in AB dot module OTS we are
importing the browser animations module
and adding it to the imports array now
if you're doing this manually make sure
to add it after the browser's module so
the command basically adds project
dependencies includes them in the module
and sets up the style and theme for your
angular application to test if it is
actually working let's use materials
button component there are three simple
steps first step imported in app dot
module dot TS import math button module
from angular slash material second step
add it to the imports array third step
use it in the HTML so in AB dot
component dot HTML wipe out the existing
HTML and add a button tag with the text
hello world but also with the directive
mat - button now let's run the
application in the terminal run the
command ng serve - OH
in the browser you can see that we have
a button that says hello world which is
styled with angular material let me
change the directive to mat raised
button
go back to the browser and you can see
the subtle difference the button is now
raised so the material library is
working perfectly fine you're probably
thinking how would I know to use math
button or math raised button right well
it's pretty simple I refer to the
documentation I can mention it is kind
of a necessity for this particular
course there is just no way that we can
know what directive has to be used for
which component this was a simple
getting started video and that is the
reason I used a simple button component
without referring to the documentation
in the upcoming videos we will be
referring the documentation more often
all right there you go
angular material working in your angular
application what we had to do was run
the command in G and at angular slash
material in the CLI project
in the last video we saw how to add a
material button component to our
application there were three simple
steps first step is to import it second
step is to add it to the imports array
and third step is to use it in the HTML
although this is perfectly fine there is
a better recommended approach and that
approach is to create a separate module
that deals with importing and exporting
material components so in the terminal
that is used the CLI to generate a new
module ng G for generate m4 module for
the by name of the module which we will
call as material
once the command completes you should
have a folder called material inside the
app folder and within the material
folder you should have material dot
module dot TS in this module we are only
concerned with importing and exporting
material components so remove common
module
as well as the declarations array
instead add an exports array
now let's move the imports from app
module to material module so from AB dot
module dot es remove the import
statement and add it in material module
make sure to remove it from the imports
array as well next in material module
create a constant
material components and then include the
map button module next add this constant
to the imports array and the exports
array
finally include the material module in
the app module in the imports are a
material module which is going to auto
import the material module from material
dot module dot TS now let's restart the
server ctrl C and then ng serve - OH
and you can see that the raised button
still has the same material styling so
what we have done is extracted material
into its own module so from the next
video to use any component all we have
to do is import it and add it to the
material components array this approach
isolates material code and also keeps
the app module nice and clean
in this video let's discuss about
typography in angular material now
typography basically deals with the
style and appearance of text on your
website if your website has text content
with way too many styles or font sizes
it kind of spoils the UI to address this
concern angular material provides
typography levels each level has a
definite font size font weight and line
height let's take a closer look at the
different type a graffiti belts to
create huge headers in the web page we
can make use of the material display
classes now there are a total of four
display classes so let me create four
div tags one for each display class in
fact that we simply copy paste the code
and then explain it so we have four dip
tags each with a different class the
topmost one is matte display for my
display three two and one if we save
this and take a look at the browser you
can see how they appear on the web page
display four has the largest size and
the size decreases as we move towards
display one when you have to really
capture the users attention this is
probably the way to go next we have four
more classes that correspond to each one
H 2 H 3 and H word tags for a section of
your web page again let me copy pasted
for more div tags we have the mat
headline class which is for an h1 tag
mat title which is equivalent to an h2
tag subheading 2 for h3 and subheading 1
for H 4 if you save the file and take a
look at the browser you can see the four
classes in action so these are also kind
of headings but smaller compared to the
display classes
the display classes you probably use
only once at the very top of your page
and the section headings like headline
can be used multiple times once for each
section alright next we have body text
and caption again let me copy paste the
div tags so for the body content in your
page that is for text other than
headings you can make use of body 1 and
if you need the text to be in bold use
body 2 and if there is a caption use the
caption class so Matt body 1 Matt body 2
and Matt caption if you take a look at
the browser you can see them in action
body one body two which is bold text and
then the caption and the final class we
have is the typography class itself and
what it does is it allows h1 to h4 tags
to be used as you would normally
you just have to wrap them in material
typography class again let me quickly
copy paste the div tags so you can see
that we have a div tag with class matte
typography and then within this div tag
we can use the regular h1 to h4 tags if
we save this and take a look at the
browser you can see that it is exactly
the same as headline title and
subheading classes so this is about
typography in angular material a set of
classes concerned with the style and
appearance of text in your application
in the next video let's discuss about
one of the most fundamental HTML
elements which is the button element
thank you guys for watching over to
subscribe I'll see you guys in the next
one
in this video let's take a look at
angular material buttons angular
material buttons are basically native
button tags or anchor tags enhanced with
material design we had a quick look at
material buttons in the getting started
video now let's take a more detailed
look to make use of material buttons we
need to import the material button
module so in material dot module dot TS
import the mat button module and added
to the material components array now
let's go back to app component dot HTML
to create the simplest of material
buttons we add the mat button attribute
so a button tag with the math button
attribute save this and take a look at
the browser and you can see a material
button now let's take a look at some of
the variants
the first variant is a raised button the
attribute is mat raised button
the mix variant is a flat button the
attribute is mat flat button
and we also have a variant that applies
just the outline the attribute is Matt
strobe button
let's save this and take a look at the
browser the buttons are too close to
each other so let's add some margin in
AB dot component dot CSS
margin-right three ram now if you go
back to the browser you can see the
different buttons raised flat and strode
apart from these we also have circular
buttons in angular material there are
again three variants the first one is an
icon button the attribute is mat icon
button
the second variant is a fab button the
attribute is mat fab
lastly a mini fire button with the
attribute mat mini fab
save the file and let's take a look at
them in the browser so we have icon
button which is a circular button with a
transparent background fab button which
is a circular button which defaults to
accent color of your theme and the mini
fab button which is just a smaller
version of the fab button so these are
the variants for circular buttons next
let's talk about button colors when it
comes to material there are three colors
we talked about primary accent and
warned colors w AR n warned to apply the
color we make use of the color attribute
on the button element let me copy paste
three buttons and add the colors
color is equal to primary
the text is primary color is equal to
accent
the text is accent and finally color is
equal to war and the text is war
if you take a look at the browser you
can see the button text in different
colors primary accent and warm how the
colors apply are based on the variant of
the button if we were to apply the same
colors to raised buttons for example
you can see the difference
primary accent and worn so based on the
type of the button the color is added to
the element the last thing I want to
show is how to disable the ripple effect
right now you can see that when I click
on the button there is a ripple
animation effect if you don't like it
for some reason you can add the disable
ripple attribute to the button element
so on this third button which is for
warm I am going to add
disable Ripple if I save this and go
back to the browser only on this button
when I click you can see that there is
no more ripple effect ripple effect no
ripple effect now those were a lot of
attributes to keep in mind so let me
point you to the documentation go to
material dot io and click on components
and then scroll to the button component
click on examples and click on the code
icon here you pretty much have all the
code required for you to experiment with
material buttons and if you visit the
API tab you can see what is the module
that needs to be imported so angular
material provides six variants and three
colors that can be applied to the native
button element buttons kind of make up a
part of few other material elements so
make sure you have a good knowledge of
them with this understanding let's take
a look at button toggle in the next
video
alright guess let's take a look at the
button toggle element in this video
button toggle is basically an element
with the appearance of a button and can
toggle between on and off states to get
started we need to import Matt button
toggle module from angular material and
add it to the material array
import it and add it to the material
components array now in the HTML we can
add Matt button toggle with the text
toggle if you save the file and take a
look at the browser you should see a
toggle button click on the button a
toggle say the on state click again and
it toggles to the off state now you
might want to use the state of the
toggle button to perform some operation
to get hold of the toggle state add a
template reference variable and then
access the checked properly on that
variable
toggle button is going to be the
template reference variable and then
interpolate toggle button dot checked if
you now take a look at the browser you
can see that the value is false click on
the button and the value is true now the
button checked value is false by default
we can change that though by adding the
checked attribute to the toggle button
element
if you now take a look at the browser
you can see that the button appearance
is that of the on state and the checked
property value is now true we of course
still have the ripple effect when we
click on the button to disable it add
the disable ripple attribute
you can see that the ripple animation is
now gone it is also possible to disable
the button itself by adding the disabled
attribute
if I now head back to the browser and
try clicking on the button nothing
happens the button is disabled and
cannot be toggled between on and off
alright these are some of the properties
on a button toggle element now although
these elements can be used individually
they are typically grouped together and
presented as better alternatives to
radio buttons or checkboxes for example
let's say you have a list of front-end
technologies let me show you how to
display them using the button toggle
element to create a group of button
toggle elements we use the Matt button
toggle group directive
within the group we can add the
individual button toggle elements
angular
react and view each of the elements need
to have a value attribute which will
point to the overall value of this group
so value is equal to angular react and
view now to access this group's value we
need to create a template reference
variable and assign Matt button toggle
group
the variable name is toggle group and to
this we assigned Matt button toggle
group now we can interpolate toggle
group dot value
to access the value of this toggle
button group let's save this and head to
the browser and you can see that we have
the button group I click on the button
and the group value is displayed angular
react and view by default the toggle
group behaves like radio buttons and
only one item can be selected at a time
if you want the behavior to be that of a
checkbox where multiple items can be
selected you simply need to add the
multiple attribute to the toggle group
element so over here I'm going to add
multiple if you now go back to the
browser you can see that we can select
multiple elements and the value is now a
comma separated list of the selections
angular react view just angular and
react just angular or all three
now what we have seen is how to get hold
of the value in the HTML you can also
listen to change events and execute some
code written in the component class as
well you can also get hold of the
template reference variable in the class
component and perform any required
operation I do have a small series on
angular component interaction where I go
in detail about using reference
variables within the component class so
please do take a look at that if you
have a necessity but this is pretty much
how you work with the button toggle
element in angular material
in this video let's take a look at the
simplest way to use angular material
icons first make sure you have a link to
material icons in your index dot HTML
this right here next import the mat icon
module from angular material and add it
to the material components array
by including Matt icon module we can now
use the Matt icon component so in the
HTML
Matt icon in between the opening and
closing tags we need to specify text
that corresponds to an icon but the
question is what text do we specify the
map icon component accepts material icon
fonts so in the browser go to material
dot io / tools slash icons and here you
can see all the material fonts available
you simply grab the text from one of the
icons and paste it as the inner HTML to
the matte icon tag if you now go back to
the browser you should see the icon
being displayed so you can select any
icon from the list and just include the
text in the matte icon component to add
a color we use the color attribute with
either primary accent or born as a value
which is retrieved
based on your theme so if I add color is
equal to primary go back to the browser
you should see the icon with the primary
color which in our case is indigo now
you can also use your own SVG's and
there is a detailed explanation on how
to use them as well so if you go to the
material dogs components under buttons
and indicators there is icon and over
here there is a good amount of
explanation on using SVG's but then
again material font has tons of icons
which might be more than enough
let's take a look at material batches in
this video if you work with bootstrap
badges should seem familiar to you they
are basically small status descriptors
for UI elements for example if you have
to display notifications for a user or
the number of unread messages in your
inbox badges are the way to go so let's
see what is possible with angular
material badges in this video
to be able to use them we first need to
import the badge module in material dot
module ts import mat badge module from
angular slash material slash badge and
then add it to the material components
array
now let's create our first badge in AB
component dot HTML I'm going to include
a span tag with the text notifications
to add a badge to the span tag we make
use of the mat badge attribute
so mad badge and this attribute is equal
to the value you want to indicate let's
go with five if we save this and take a
look at the browser you should see the
badge in action the small circular
element on the top right of the span
text now this is the most basic badge
you can have let's see how to customize
this and let's start with the position
by default a badge is placed above and
after the element it is associated with
that is to the top right we can control
the position using the Matt badge
position attribute so back in the HTML
I'm going to make three more copies of
this div tag
and I'm going to specify the Matt badge
position attribute
below and before
below and after
above and before let me also add some
margin to the div tags to make sure that
there is enough spacing between the
elements so div margin 3 REMS now if you
save the files and take a look at the
browser you can see the different
positions above and after below and
before below and after above and before
some at badge position attribute to
control the position of the badge next
let's talk about badge sizing we can
specify the size using the Matt badge
size attribute the possible values are
small medium and large with medium being
the default value I'm going to make
three more copies of our notification
badge and for the first one I'm going to
add Mac badge size is equal to small the
second one medium which is also the
default and for the third one large if
we now save the file and take a look at
the browser you can see the badges which
are small medium and large
alright next we have badge coloring the
badge background color can be set using
the mat badge color attribute possible
values our primary accent and born with
primary being the default value the
color of course is determined by the
theme your application is using so back
in vs code I'm going to make three more
copies of the original notification
badge
for the first one I'm going to add math
badge color is equal to primary which is
the default for the second one it is
going to be accent and for the third one
it's going to be warned if we save this
and take a look at the browser you can
see primary accent and worn colors based
on your theme
now you might have noticed in all the
notification badges the badge overlaps
with the text the overlap lag though can
be controlled as well we specify the
Matt patch overlap attribute and set it
defaults back in vs code on the last
badge I'm going to add the attribute
Matt batch overlap is equal to false if
you go back to the browser you can see
that the batch doesn't overlap with the
text anymore
in fact material documentation advises
us to overlap badges for icons and not
for text for example if you have the
inbox icon then overlapping might be a
good choice for text however try
avoiding overlap as much as possible
finally let's talk about binding values
and also conditional rendering the value
for a batch is usually stored in a class
property to bind the value we simply use
property binding so I'm going to open
app component es and over here I'm going
to create a new property notifications
is equal to two and then in the HTML on
the very first badge I'm going to have
property binding on the mat badge
attribute so square brackets for
property binding and the property we
want to bind to is notifications
this property right here so now if we go
back to the browser
the very first batch now indicates - now
sometimes you might also want to
conditionally render based on the number
of notifications for example when
notifications is zero it doesn't really
make sense to indicate that we rather
hide the badge itself we can do that
using mad badge hidden attribute so back
an app component I'm going to add the
condition property binding with mat
badge hidden
and this is going to be equal to the
condition notifications is equal to zero
now if we take a look at the browser you
can still see the badge to go back to vs
code change the value to zero
and you can see that the
is now hidden that is how you
conditionally render a badge in angular
material using the mad badge hidden
attribute alright that's pretty much
what I have about badges
let me quickly point you to the
documentation so go to material dot io
components under buttons and indicators
there is badge and if you go to the API
tab you will know what has to be
imported
let's take a look at the progress
spinner in this video first let's import
the module Matt progress spinner module
included in the material components
array of this module basically provides
us with two spinner components Matt
progress spinner and Matt spinner the
first one Matt progress spinner is a
determinate spinner which has a value
attribute that can be between zero and
hundred so Matt progress spinner with
the value attribute is equal to let's go
with 40 if you take a look at the
browser you can see a spinner that is at
40% value we can also specify the value
as 0 in which case you cannot see any
spinner at all and a value of 100 which
shows the complete spinner you can also
bind to the value attribute
programmatically to indicate any
progress that has to be conveyed to the
user now a more common use case of the
spinner is the indeterminate spinner or
the spinner that never stops spinning
for that we make use of the Matt spinner
component
if we now save the file and
take a look at the browser you can see
that we have a progress winner that
spins indefinitely you would want to use
this to indicate to the user that
something is running in the background
and the UI is busy for example if you
are loading data it is a good idea to
show the spinner and then hide it when
the data has loaded
let me mock the loading of data with a
button click so I'm going to go back to
AB dot component dirtiest and create a
new property
show spinner and initialize it to false
I'm also going to define a method load
data and in this method initially we are
going to set show spinner to true this
Dodger spinner is equal to true and then
we use set timeout to set it back to
false after five seconds
so error function this dot shows spinner
is equal defaults in the HTML let me use
the ng if condition with show spinner
and also create a button that calls the
load data method
and gif is equal to show spinner and a
button load data
on-click this is going to be load data
now let's go back to the browser and
initially you can see that the spinner
is hidden I click on load data and the
spinner appears this indicates to the
user the data is being fetched and after
five seconds the spinner disappears
which again can indicate that the data
has been loaded now ideally you want a
separate component with more styling
like an overlay and a z-index so that
nothing else can be clicked when data is
being loaded or even a form being
submitted and also by default the color
is set to primary color of the theme but
again like other components you can set
the color attribute to accent or warn as
well so mad spinner color is equal to
accent
and now we have an accent color spinner
so that is about the progress spinner
now similar to the progress spinner
there is also the progress bar indicator
in angular material it works almost the
same as progress spinner so I will leave
it up to you guys to experiment and
understand how it works well that is
about buttons and indicators in angular
material from the next video let's take
a look at the different components
related to navigation
let's take a look at navigation
components starting with the toolbar
typically the toolbar displays
information and actions relating to the
current screen it's used for branding
screen titles navigation and actions in
this video though we will only focus on
how the toolbar can be used as a navbar
now the first step is to import the
material toolbar module in material
module dot TS in the import statement ad
mat toolbar module also included in the
material components array
now that I think of it the re name is
slightly misleading so I'm going to
replace material components with the
name just material
all right now that we have imported the
module we can use the component in the
HTML so in AB component dot HTML the
component is mat toolbar
within the toolbar I'm going to add a
span tag that says code evolution
if you now save this and take a look at
the browser you should be able to see a
basic toolbar we can add the color to
this toolbar using the color attribute
the color attribute accepts either
primary accent or worn as its value
let's go with primary
if you head back to the browser you
should be able to see a primary color
toolbar in your application now let's
see how to convert this basic tool bar
into a navbar anavar typically consists
of the brand title on the left and a
group of links on the right Mindi
convert our span tag into a div tag
which is going to be our brand code
evolution I'm also going to add another
div tag with a set of links I'm going to
add three span tags one for home
one for about and one for services if
you save the file and take a look at the
browser you can see that it doesn't
exactly look like a navbar but all we
need is to distribute the space in the
toolbar in between the title and the
links so in the CSS which is AB dot
component dot CSS I'm going to add a
class navbar
and specify justify content to be space
between let me also add some spacing
between the span tags padding right one
Ram finally add the nav bar class to the
toolbar so in AB component dot HTML on
the mat toolbar component class is equal
to nav bar now if we take a look at the
browser you should have a proper navbar
brand on the left and a set of links on
the right and the styling is completely
up to you but a toolbar is what you need
to use to create a nav bar in angular
material
in this video let's take a look at side
nav and angular material the first step
as always is to import the module say
material module dot es import mat side
nav module and add it to the material
array now we can add the side nav to our
application
to set up a site now we use three
components the first one is Matt site
nap container which acts as a container
to the site nav as well as the main
content within the container we have mat
side nav
which represents the site content
and then we have mapped site nap content
which represents the main content it is
important that the site content and the
main content are placed within the
container if you don't want some
elements to be affected by this
container for example header and footer
you can place them outside the sitemap
container all right if we now save the
file and take a look at the browser the
output is not quite what we expect
we can see the main content for the site
now is not seen let me tell you that
this is the expected behavior site nav
is always hidden by default there are a
couple of ways to open or show the side
nav the simplest way is to add the
opened attribute on the mat side nav
component
if you now say the file and take a look
at the browser you should be able to see
the site now as well the UI though is
not clear so let me add some basic
styling back in vs code and AB dot
component dot CSS I'm going to add mat a
side nav container has a height of a
hundred percent mat side nav and mat
side nav content let's add some padding
and finally just for the side nav I'm
going to add a background color light
coral and a width of 200 pixels
if we now take a look at the browser it
is much more clear the site now appears
like an overlay on the main content and
when I click outside the side nav it
closes and we can see the main content
now once we close it though there is no
way to open it again
so rather than setting the opened
attribute like here let's bind it to a
property which we can then control using
a button we will be using two-way
binding so the first step is to import
the forms module in app module so open
up dot module dot ES
in Port forms module and add it to the
imports array
now let's go back to two-way binding an
AB component dot es which is the
component class I am going to create a
new property called opened and set it to
false next in the HTML bind the opened
attribute to the opened property and
create a button that will toggle the
opened property value so for two-way
binding we use banana in a box in tax so
square brackets parenthesis and close it
this is going to be equal to the
property we just created opened next as
part of the main content I'm going to
add a button the text is going to be
toggle opened and on click of this
button so click handler we simply toggle
the open value
opened is equal to not off opened if you
now say the files and take a look at the
browser the sitemap should be initially
hidden because we have initialized it to
false I click on the button and the side
nav is shown click outside the side nav
and it automatically hides so this is
the first method to show or hide the
side nav before we take a look at the
next method I want to quickly show you
the different modes that can be applied
to a side nav the mode for a side nav
can be specified using the mode
attribute on the mat side nav component
the default mode is over mode is equal
to over and this is the mode we have
seen so far if you go back to the
browser you can see that there is no
change from what we have already seen
the site now floats over the main
content which is covered by a backdrop
the second possible value for the mold
attribute is push so I'm going to change
over to push let's see how this works in
the browser I click on the button the
site map appears but this time the site
map pushes the primary content out of
its way covering it with a backdrop now
the final possible mode is side so mode
is equal to side
in this mode the side nav appears
side-by-side with the main content
shrinking the main contents width to
make space for the side nav so the three
possible modes are over push and side
I'm going to stick with site for the
rest of this video now back to opening
and closing the side nav we have seen
the first method which is using the
opened attribute the second way to open
or close the side nav is by invoking the
open or close methods on the side nav
itself for this method I will create a
template reference variable on the mat
side nav component hash symbol and side
nav now I can create two buttons that
will call the open and close methods on
this template reference variable button
open on click it is going to call side
nav dot open similarly button close on
click side nav dot close let's save this
file and go back to the browser I click
on open and the side nav opens I click
on close and the side nav closes so this
is the second method the third method is
to simply toggle the side nav by calling
the toggle method this is also the
approach you might want to take when you
have a hamburger icon for example I will
create another button in the main
content and the text is going to be
toggled
on click of this button I simply call
the toggle method on the side nav
reference variable side nav dot toggle
if I now go back to the browser click on
the toggle button it opens I click again
it closes so these are the three methods
and if at all you want to perform some
action on open or close off the side nav
you can listen to the opened and closed
events now back in vs code in AB
component Diaz I am going to create a
method called log which accepts a
parameter called state and simply logs
that to the console
now in the HTML we can listen to opened
and closed events and call our log
method passing in the appropriate value
so on mat side nav listen to opened
event
and call the log method passing in the
string opened similarly on the closed
event called the method passing in the
string closed if you now head back to
the browser open dev tools click on
toggle you should see the message opened
toggle again you should see the message
closed now I am simply logging a message
but you can perform any action that
seems fit for your application so that
is about the side nav in angular
material
all right let's take a look at menus in
this video basically a menu displays a
list of choices on a temporary surface
the choices appear when users interact
with the button action or some other
type of control now as always the first
step is to import the appropriate module
so in material dot module Diaz I'm going
to import mat menu module and add it to
the material array
now let's go to app component dot HTML
and over here to create a menu we use
the math menu component to specify the
choices for a menu we use the button
elements with a math menu item attribute
button fronton is the text and we add
the mat menu item attribute
similarly let's also have backand as a
menu item if you save this and take a
look at the browser you're not going to
see anything that is because by itself
the Matt menu element does not render
anything it has to be triggered from a
UI element or programmatically so let's
add an element to open the menu I'm
going to add a button element and add
the attribute mat flat button for some
styling the text is going to be menu now
that we have the element we need to
associate the menu with this element and
that is a quick two step process first
step on the mat menu component create a
template reference variable and assign
to it the mat menu directive up menu is
the variable name and assign mat menu
second step link the button with the
template reference variable using the
mat menu trigger for directive so on
this button mat menu trigger for and
then assign the reference variable app
menu in simple English hey there is a
menu called
app menu which can be triggered by this
menu button now if we say the file and
take a look at the browser we have the
menu button click on the button and you
can see the menu so this is how you
create a basic menu next let's see how
to create a nested menu the first step
is to create the submenu and we are
going to repeat the process of creating
a menu and attaching a template
reference variable so mat menu I'm going
to add three menu items
the first one is going to be angular the
second one react and the turbulent view
on the mat menu component I'm going to
add the reference variable this is going
to be called sub menu and we assigned
the map menu directive all right we have
created a sub menu and this is a sub
menu for the front end choice in the
main menu so all we have to do is add
the trigger directive again on this item
map menu trigger for submenu in simple
English
hey this front-end menu choice is going
to trigger this submenu if we save this
and take a look at the browser you can
see that we have the nested menu you
don't have to click on front-end when
you hover on the choice the submenu is
opened angular react and view and one of
the useful options when it comes to a
menu is with respect to the positioning
of the menu we have X position and y
position attributes so on the map menu
component we can specify X position and
white position X position can take
values of before or after and Y position
can take values of above or below let's
go with after and above
if you take a look at the browser click
on menu you can see that the menu opens
to the right so exposition is working
fine but the menu still opens below the
button and that is simply because there
is no space available at the top let's
reposition the button in the CSS file
let me add a class
Center margin is going to be 10 REMS
back in the HTML let's add the class to
the button element
now if we go back to the browser and
click on the element you can see that
the menu opens to the right and to the
top so x position and y position before
after for exposition about and below for
y position these attributes control the
position of the menu now the last thing
I want to talk about is lazy rendering
by default the menu choices are
initialized even before the menu is
opened that is even before clicking on
the menu button the choices have already
been said for the menu we can differ
initialization until the menu is open
using the ng template directive and mat
menu content attribute this allows us to
have dynamic content as many choices
let's see how I'm going to create a new
menu
Matt menu I'm going to add a reference
variable called lazy menu and set it to
Matt menu within the menu component we
are going to use the ng template
directive and within this directive we
specify the menu items the first one is
going to be a Settings button and the
second one is going to be the text
logout now what I am going to do is
create to trigger buttons to this same
menu button the text is going to be
vishwas Matt menu trigger four is equal
to lazy menu
similarly another button that says code
evolution and we trigger the same lazy
menu if we now save the file and take a
look at the browser if I click on
Vishwas the menu is not quite opening
and that is because we left out the Matt
menu content attribute on the ng
template tag so let's save the file and
try again
I'm going to go back to the browser
click on Vishwas and you can see we have
the menu click on code evolution and you
can see that we have the same menu again
now what we want is if I click on wish
wasps I mean the choice to be logout
vishwas and if I click on code evolution
I want the menu to say logout code
evolution basically we are looking at
dynamic choices for that we make use of
math menu trigger data attribute so back
in the component HTML on the trigger
buttons we add in an extra attribute
this attribute is mat menu trigger data
this is going to be equal to an object
let's pass in a name which is vishwas
similarly on the second trigger button
we're going to pass in name but this
time it is going to be code evolution
now I've just reformatted this and we
have the two buttons still in place one
for vishwas and one for code evolution
now that we have specified the data on
the ng template tag we create a local
variable let name is equal to name and
in the menu choice we can now use
interpolation with that variable double
curly braces and name now if we go back
to the browser
click on vishwas it says log out vishwas
and if I click on code evolution it says
log out code evolution so what is
happening is on the trigger button we
specify the map menu trigger data
attribute and we specify the name so we
are saying hey I know that this button
is a trigger for a menu but when I am
triggering that menu let me pass some
additional information that the menu can
use to dynamically render some data now
in the map menu component we use the ng
template tag and on the ng template tag
we specify this name variable that we
want to access and that can be
interpolated in the button element that
is how we have log out vishwas let's add
one more property so that we really
understand how it works to the trigger
data object I'm going to add a new
property called hobby for vishwas the
hobby is football and for code evolution
the hobby is teaching now in the menu on
the ng template tag we declare another
variable
let hobby is equal to hobby and now we
can add a new menu choice and bind the
hobby so button hobby is mind hobby and
let me also add mad menu item if we now
save the file and take a look at the
browser click on the choise hobby is
football click on code evolution hobby
is teaching you can see that we have
different menu choices for the two
elements say menu with dynamic content
all right that is about navigation and
menus in angular material
let me quickly point you to the
documentation go to components go to
navigation menu API for the module that
you have to import and then the examples
to take a look at some of the examples
you can use in the next section let's
take a look at components related to
layouts in angular material
angular material provides a number of
components for laying out elements let's
begin with the list component in this
video first step is to import the module
so in material module Diaz import mat
list module and added to the material
array now in the HTML we can create a
basic list mat list is the component and
this component has mat list item
as its children if we save this and take
a look at the browser you can see that
we have a list of items being displayed
now suppose you have a list where the
list item is just a lot of text for such
scenarios we have the dense attribute
apply it on the mat list component and
it will reduce the font size if you take
a look at the browser you can see that
the font size has been reduced the mat
list module also provides components to
create a navigation list the component
is mat named list as children to this
component you have to specify anchor
tags with the mat list item attribute so
anchor tag
Matt list item attribute
and let's just add each ref is equal to
a hashtag I'm going to create two more
list items
about and services if you save the file
and take a look at the browser you can
see that we have a navigation list a
good place for this would be the sitemap
component which we learned earlier in
the series now it is also possible to
create multiline lists and also include
material icons I'm going to comment this
out and start a new list some add lists
and within the Mathis component we are
going to have a mat list item within the
list item we can add a material icon
Matt icon and let's go with home we can
then add a heading with Matt line
attribute after that a paragraph with a
matte line attribute if you save this
and take a look at the browser you can
see that the list item has two lines one
for heading and one for the paragraph we
also have the icon and it looks like
I've forgotten the attribute on Matt
icon so let's add Matt list icon
if we save this and take a look at the
browser you can see that the list item
has two lines one for heading and one
for the paragraph we also have the icon
to the left let me add another list item
I'm going to copy this mat list item
component paste it I'm going to change
home to folder this is going to be
heading 2 and then line to save the file
and take a look at the browser we have
two items in the list which contain
multiple lines now you can see that we
don't really have a clear distinction
between the list items for that purpose
angular material provides another module
namely mat divider module so in material
module TS let's import it then add it to
the material array mat divider module
now in the HTML in between the two list
items we can add the mat divider
component so right after the first list
item mat divider now if we take a look
at the browser you can see that there is
a clear separation between the list
items right now we have the list items
hard-coded but typically you would use
the mg4 directive on an array of data so
to create lists you can use the mat list
and mat divider modules let's take a
look at grids in the next video
all right let's take a look at the
material grid list in this video the
grid list is basically a two dimensional
list view that arranged ourselves into
grid-based layout now the first step is
to import the module so in material
Mario Diaz import mat grid list module
and added to the material array mat grid
list module now we can create a grid
list the component is mat grid list and
this component requires a calls
attribute which specifies the number of
columns in the grid let's go with two
columns so calls is equal to two as
children to this component we specify
Matt grid tile components
title 1 and similarly let's create three
more also to be able to clearly see the
grid let's add a background color to the
tiles so in the CSS file Matt grid tile
background color light blue now if we
save this and take a look at the browser
you can see the grid with two columns
and two rows the question is how did it
create the two rows for a grid we always
specify the number of columns and the
number of rows is determined by how many
columns we want and the number of tiles
specified since we have 4 tiles and two
columns it can fit only two tiles in
each row hence it creates an additional
row to fit the next two tiles if you
were to have five tiles there would be
three rows so the number of rows is
determined by some basic math of course
you can also specify how many rows or
columns each tile should take up that
can be specified using the row span and
called span attributes on tile one if I
said row span is equal to two and take a
look at the browser you can see that it
takes up two rows instead of one
similarly if I said call span is equal
to two
you can see that it takes up two columns
instead of one when specifying called
span though you need to make sure that
it does not exceed the calls attribute
if it does it throws an error all right
next let's talk about the height of each
row in the grid by default the height of
a row is equal to the width of a column
however you can override this using the
row height attribute and you can specify
one of the three values the first one is
a straightforward value so row height is
equal to a hundred pixels take a look at
the browser and you can see that each
row will be a hundred pixels tall the
second option is to specify the row
height as a ratio with respect to the
column width for example row height is
equal to 2 is to 1 this implies that the
row height is 1/2 the column width if
the column width is 200 pixels then the
row height is a hundred pixels take a
look at the browser and you can clearly
see from each style that the height
looks half the width the third option is
to fit the height based on the container
so row height is equal to fit but this
time we also need to specify a height
for the container so style height 200
pixels now if we take a look at the
browser the rows are fit into the
container height of 200 pixels so each
row has a height of 100 pixels if there
were 4 rows each row would be 50 pixels
so as to fit the total container height
of 200 pixels all right the last
attribute I want to discuss on a good
list is the gutter size that is spacing
between the tiles we can specify gutter
size using the gutter size property
let's go with gutter size
is equal to 10 pixels if you save the
file and take a look at the browser you
should now see additional spacing
between the different tiles
welcome back everyone in this video
let's take a look at expansion panels
and accordions in angular material
expansion panels are basically panels
which can collapse or expand to display
additional details in a view let's take
a look at some examples to get started
import matte expansion module and add it
to the material array so in material
module Diaz imported
and add it to the material array now in
the HTML let's create an expansion panel
the component to use is matte expansion
panel every panel must contain a panel
header component
it is this header which is displayed
when the panel is collapsed a header can
contain a title and a description we use
math panel title
to add the title angular fundamentals
and mat panel description to add a short
description for the panel total duration
three hours if you now save the file and
take a look at the browser we should
have an expansion panel you can see the
title and the description as well when I
click on the header the panel expands
right now the panel content is empty
let's go back and add some text outside
the header but within the expansion
panel I'm going to add a paragraph this
is the panel content add course details
material also provides an action row
component which I'm going to add here
mat action row a button tag with the
text enroll
and Matt button attribute if you now
take a look at the browser we have the
panel I click on the header and we have
the panel content a paragraph tag and
the action row which floats the Android
button to the right the panel details
can be any HTML you wish to and is not
limited to a paragraph tag but this is
pretty much how you create a basic
expansion panel with angular material
next let's take a look at creating
accordions an accordion is basically
multiple expansion panels grouped
together let's start off by duplicating
the existing panel and changing the
header and the description
I will change the title to angular
material
and the total duration to two hours I
believe the content and action row as is
if you now take a look at the browser we
should have two panels the two panels
don't work independently of each other
let's add the Matt accordion component
to convert these panels into an
accordion
so back in vs code I'm going to add the
Matt accordion component
and the two expansion panels are
children of this component if we now
take a look at the browser we still have
the two panels but this time when you
try to expand the second panel the first
one collapses automatically the
accordion also adds a bit of margin
between the panels which would otherwise
not be present now if at all you want
multiple panels to be shown at the same
time you can set multi is equal to true
on the mat accordion component
if you take a look at the browser you
can see that we can now expand both the
panels at the same time and if you
notice to the right of the panel header
we have the toggle icon if at all for
some reason you want to hide this simply
add the height toggle attribute on the
accordion hide toggle take a look at the
browser now it is hidden now there are a
couple of methods which could be useful
depending on your requirement so I will
leave them for you to explore the
methods are pretty much like what we
have already seen in some of the other
components there are methods to open or
close the panel's programmatically and
also events to know when a panel is
expanded or collapsed but this is pretty
much the gist on how to create expansion
panels and accordions with angular
material
the next layered component we are going
to talk about is cards a cart is a
container for content and actions about
a single topic first step as always is
to import the module so in material
module Diaz we're going to import mat
card module and add it to the material
array now we can create a basic card in
the HTML the component is Matt - card
and I'm going to add the text basic card
if you take a look at the browser you
should be able to see a basic card now
angular material provides a few
predefined sections that can be used
inside this mat card component let's
take a look at them at the top we
usually have a card title so we are
going to add mat card title with the
text card title after that we have the
text content displayed using the card
content section so mat card content and
I'm going to add the text this is the
card content and finally at the bottom
we have a section for user actions for
example
button clicks the component is mat card
actions component and within the tags
I'm going to add a button that says
login and I'm going to add mat flat
button attribute
now if we save this and take a look at
the browser you can see that we have the
title the content and the action section
now if you want the button right aligned
we can do so using the align attribute
on the actions section a line is equal
to end now take a look at the browser
and you can see that the action section
is right aligned and this is the basic
idea behind cards there are a couple
more sections with which you can truly
build any card layout that you wish to
so let me point you to the documentation
in components under layout card and then
under examples you can see a
full-fledged application of a card it
has a header with an avatar title
subtitle and image content and actions
you can also build your own cards for a
registration form a login form pricing
section user profiles and a lot more one
component to fulfill a variety of
requirements now if you want the code
for this particular card just click on
View source and you have the HTML
in this video let's take a look at tabs
in angular material tabs basically allow
you to organize content into separate
views where only one view can be visible
at a given time
now first step let's import the tabs
module say material module TS we're
going to import mat tabs module and add
it to the material array
now we can create tabs in the HTML the
component is mat tab group
and within the opening and closing tags
each tab is represented using the mat
tab component
each tab will have a label and the
content let's add the labels angular
react and view
and the content as angular content react
content and view content
now if you save the files and take a
look at the browser you should see three
tabs one each for angular react and view
if you want to know which tab is active
at any point of time you can use the
selected index property so back in the
HTML add a template reference variable
on mat tab group
and then we can use interpolation to
view the property value tab Rev dot
selected index if you take a look at the
browser you can see that initially it
displays 0 because index starts from 0
click on react it changes to 1 and view
changes to 2 now if you want to perform
some operation when you are changing
tabs you can listen to the selected tab
change event so back in the HTML
bind to selected tab change and as an
event handler
let's call log change and pass in the
selected index
in the component class I'm going to
simply lock the index to the console
now if you go back to the browser
open the console and change the index
you can see the selected index being
logged so when the tab changes you can
perform any operation you want to using
the selected tab change event
the last layout related component we are
going to take a look at is the stepper
component steppers basically can make
progress through numbered steps let's
take a look at an example
first up import map stepper module and
add it to the material array
now we can create our stuffer in the
HTML there are two types of steppers
horizontal and vertical first let's take
a look at the horizontal stepper and
later on switch to the vertical stepper
to create a horizontal stepper we use
the mat horizontal stepper component
within this component to specify the
individual steps we use the mat step
component
for each step we specify the label using
the label attribute and the content goes
in between the opening and closing tags
let's create three steps we can all
relate to that is the checkout process
of an e-commerce site so step one is
going to be for shipping address
step2 for billing address and step3 for
placing an order if you now save the
files and take a look at the browser you
should be able to see the horizontal
stepper we have three steps each step
has a label and a numeric value
indicating the step you can click on the
label to navigate to the particular step
once you navigate a widow the icon
changes from the numeric value to the
Edit icon
so the stepper basically gives you an
idea of your progress through the
checkout process right now we are
navigating to the different steps by
clicking on the label however stepper
also supports a previous and Next button
out of the box all you have to do is
include the map stepper previous and
match stepper next directives so for the
billing address step let me add both
these buttons
button back this is going to be Matt
button for styling and then Matt stepper
previous to go back one step
similarly we have the next button
if you now go back to the browser we
should have these two buttons under
billing address if I click on back we go
back one step and if I click on next
we go forward one step so these are the
stepper buttons next let's talk about
linear steps if you have noticed we can
jump from step one to step two and then
to step three without any restrictions
in certain situations though you want
the user to complete a step before they
can proceed with the subsequent steps
linear steppers are meant exactly for
that to convert a regular stepper into a
linear stepper there are two steps the
first step is to add the linear
attribute to the mat horizontal stepper
component
linear the second step is to add a
completed attribute to the individual
steps to each step I will add attribute
and set it defaults
if you now go back to the browser I
click on billing address you can see
that we are not navigated to step two
step one is not completed and hence we
cannot proceed if I change step one
completed to true
you can see that now we can proceed to
step two and since step two is not
completed we cannot proceed to step 3
and for this example I am hard-coding
true or false but ideally you need to
have properly winding with this
completed property based on your
requirements after the user interacts
with the step call a method that will
update the completed property to true
which will then allow the user to
navigate to the next step and if at all
you do have a step which is optional you
can simply place the optional attribute
on that particular step on step two I
will add the attribute optional and now
if you go back to the browser you can
see that we can navigate all the way to
step three even though we have completed
attribute set to false for step number
two you can also see the optional text
being displayed for building address all
right what we have seen is a horizontal
stepper you can also create vertical
steppers with angular material simply
change mat horizontal stepper to mat
vertical stepper
and you can see that we have the exact
same stepper but this time with vertical
orientation well that is about
components related to layout in angular
material starting next video let's take
a look at components related to forms
in this video let's take a look at the
components related to an input in
angular material when it comes to
controls like inputs text areas and
select we always discuss them in
relation to a common wrapper component
and that is the form field component so
when you talk about an input component
you're effectively talking about the for
field component and the input component
let's take a closer look at both those
components in this video the first step
is to import the two concerned modules
so in material module dot es I'm going
to import mat form field module and mat
input module
make sure to add them to the material
array as well
now we can create our first input
control so in AB component HTML I'm
going to add mat form field and within
these tags I'm going to add input with a
matte input attribute please make note
that every input element has to have
this form field wrapper and to the input
element itself we add the mat input
attribute now if I save this and take a
look at the browser you can see that we
have the most basic material input
element let's see how we can customize
this input control first up let's see
how to add a label to the input field so
to add a label use the mat label
component so within the mat form field
opening tag mat label and let's call
this name if you take a look at the
browser you can see the label it behaves
as a placeholder when there is no text
start typing and the label floats to the
top and this is the default behavior we
can of course change this so on the form
field make use of the float label
attribute to control the behavior of the
label
so float label can be set to never in
which case the label will not float and
is hidden when you type something you
can also set it to always
in which case the label is floating even
when there is no text in the input and
you can also set it to auto which is the
default value
another important point is how the label
is presented for a required form field
so if I mark the input element as
required
you can see that now the label has the
asterisk automatically appended no
additional styling is required if you
want to disable this behavior you can
make use of the height required marker
attribute on the form field so height
required marker if I go back to the
browser the asterisk is not present for
a required field the next thing we can
do with the form field is setting a hint
label for that we make use of the matte
hint component so within the form field
I'm going to add matte hint and let's
have min five characters if you take a
look at the browser you can see that the
hint is placed right below the input and
by default it is left aligned we can
right align it using the align attribute
and setting it to a value of end so Matt
hint a line is equal to end if you go
back to the browser you can see that the
hint is now right aligned next let's
talk about appearance we can control the
appearance of the font field using the
appearance attribute by default the
appearance has a value of legacy which
is what we've seen so far so appearance
is equal to legacy we also have an
appearance value of standard and this is
just an updated version with more
consistent spacing so I'm going to copy
pasted it and change appearance legacy
to standard if I save this and go back
to the browser you can see that there is
slight difference in how the spacing is
for the standard appearance now we have
two more appearances fill and outline so
this is going to be fill this is going
to be outline the fill appearance this
plays the form filled with a filled
background and the outline appearance
shows the form filled with a border all
the way around and not just an underline
so if I go back to the browser you can
see that we have a filled input element
and then we also have one which has
border all the way around so this is
Phil and this is appearance outline
finally let's discuss about theming by
default the colors reflect the primary
color of the theme we can set the color
attribute to accent and also warn if
required so on the form field color is
equal to accent and on this one color is
equal to warn if you now take a look at
the browser the first control is accent
themed and the second is warning themed
now on a side note please go through the
documentation on how to incorporate
other messages with form fields it
requires a bit of knowledge on angular
forms concepts which I will not be
covering here but the documentation is
pretty clear so you should be in a good
position all right that is about the
input control wrapped inside a form
field component in the next video let's
take a look at the Select control
in this video let's take a look at the
material select component which is a
form control for selecting a value from
a set of options the first step is to
import the module so in material Model
Ts we're going to import mat select
module and add it to the material array
now we can create our first material
select component the material select
component just like the input component
has to be wrapped inside the form field
component some add form field now the
component for a select control is map
select within the select component we
add a label using the mat label
component the label is going to be topic
every option for this select control is
specified using the mat option component
so mat option and let's create three of
them each option will have the inner
text which the user can see and a value
which is sent to the server so we are
going to have angular react and view all
entitled case which can be seen in the
browser and the same all in lower case
as the corresponding value which will be
sent to the server so mat option value
is equal to angular value is equal to
react and value is equal to view so we
have the label and the three options and
there is the small correction the label
has to be outside the mat select
component so the label goes inside mat
form field if we save this and take a
look at the browser you can see that we
have a basic material select control the
label is shown by default and when you
select a value the label floats to the
top now we have already discussed the
features of the form field component
about labels
hence appearance and theming so I'm not
going to demo them again in this video
instead we're going to focus only on the
Select component the first thing you
might want to do is track the value of
the select control and that can easily
be done using two-way binding so back in
vs code in the component class create a
new property called selected value this
is of type string next in the HTML we
two-way bind to that property so on mat
select we're going to add to a binding
so banana in a box value is what we bind
to this is going to be equal to selected
value to view the value in the browser
let's interpolate it now if we take a
look at the browser we don't have a
value displayed select a topic and its
corresponding value is displayed the
value displayed reflects the value
attribute in the HTML
sometimes you might want an option to
clear out the selected value in such a
scenario use an option with no value
attribute so we are going to add another
option Matt option and the text is going
to be none and there is no value
attribute so now if you go back to the
browser select a value and the value is
displayed select none and the value is
reset the next feature possible with
material select is grouping related
options under a particular subheading
and for that we make use of the material
option group component so back in vs
code I'm going to replace the existing
options with a set of options that are
saved in my clipboard so what we now
have is Matt option for none and then we
have Matt option group component with a
particular label and this is the label
that groups these three Matt option
components so angular react view will be
displayed under a label of web and
similarly ionic and react native will be
displayed under the category label of
mobile if we save this and take a look
at the browser you can see that we now
have the topics grouped under sub
heading we have none we have web which
cannot be selected and then we have the
options under web angular react and view
similarly we have mobile which is the
label that can't be selected and under
mobile we have ionic and react native so
that is about grouping together the
options and it is also possible to
although multiple selections all we have
to do is add the multiple attribute on
the select component so on Matt select
add multiple now if you take a look at
the browser the options turn into
checkboxes and you can toggle selection
on multiple options so we now have
angular and react and the corresponding
value is
displayed all right those are some of
the properties of angular materials
select component and the reason I call
the options line by line and not use an
mg for directive is simply because ng 4
is not an angular material concept I
want to help you understand the
possibilities with angular material and
how you want to use it or improve it is
completely up to you so in the next
video let's take a look at autocomplete
in angular material
in this video let's take a look at
autocomplete in angular material step
one as always is to import the
appropriate module say material dot
module dot es we import Matt
autocomplete module and add it to the
material array now we can create our
first order complete let's go back to
the HTML and start off with a form tag
within the form tag Matt formfield an
input element type is equal to text and
add the Matt input attribute if you save
this and take a look at the browser we
should have a basic input element the
next step is to create a list of options
the need to be displayed as autocomplete
options so in the component class I'm
going to add three options
angular react and view the next step is
to make use of the autocomplete
component to display this list of
options the component for autocomplete
is matte autocomplete so right after the
input element matte or a complete to
specify the options we use the matte
option component and to iterate over the
list of options we will be using the mg4
directive so on map option ng for is
equal to
let option of options we are also going
to have property binding to value this
is going to be equal to option which is
from the current iteration and we are
going to display the option so basically
the value and what we display is going
to be angular react or view all right
now we have an input element and an
autocomplete with options the final step
is to link the two together on the order
complete component we add a reference
variable and assign to it Matt
autocomplete on the input element we add
the Matt order complete property and
bind it with the reference variable so
this is going to be equal to auto this
right here if you now save the files and
take a look at the browser I click on
the input element and we get the list of
options angular react and view click on
an option and it fills the value for us
so we have a basic autocomplete up and
running now it's also quite possible
that your list of options is not simply
an area of strings instead it could very
well be an area of objects for example
an array of four objects which has key
value pairs so copy-pasted a new array
called object options which is an array
of four objects each of the objects have
name angular angular material react and
view now to display the options
correctly in the HTML we interpolate
option
dot name name is a property in each of
these objects
and of course make sure to iterate over
object options now if we now save the
file and take a look at the browser the
options are displayed correctly but when
you select an option the autocomplete
doesn't display that value properly to
let the autocomplete know that it has to
use the name property to display as
value you can specify a display function
so back in the component class I'm going
to define the display function display
function the function gets each object
as a parameter I'm going to call the
parameter as subject and if at all there
is a subject we return subject dot name
else undefined now in the HTML on the
autocomplete component we add the
display width directive and assign the
function
if you now take a look at the browser
the order complete works as expected
the display value is angular but the
selected value from the autocomplete
would be the entire object now this is
great but what you might be looking for
is the filter autocomplete as you start
typing in the text the options are
narrowed down now this is where things
start to get a little complicated to be
able to implement a filtered or to
complete you need to have a decent
knowledge of angular forms angular forms
is out of scope for this series but you
can find the complete series on angular
forms on my channel if you feel lost
please go through that series and then
try to understand how a filtered
autocomplete works all right the first
step is to import reactive forms module
and add it to the imports array so in AB
dot module dot ES import reactive forms
module from angular slash forms and add
it to the imports array
step to create a form control and link
it to the input element so in AB
component or TS which is the class
component we're going to import form
control from angular slash forms and
create a new form control so in the
class my control is equal to new form
control and on the input element form
control is going to be equal to my
control so we created the form control
and linked it to the input element third
step we use the help of rxjs to create a
filtered list of options so nap
component or TS begin by making the
necessary imports we need observable
from rxjs
and map and start with operators from
rxjs next we need a new property this is
going to be filtered options this is
going to be an observable of an array of
strings next we need to implement the ng
on in it
lifecycle hook so from angular slash
core we're going to import on in it an
app component is going to implement
on in it and we can now define the
lifecycle hook so ng on in it and within
this method we are going to have this
dot filtered options equal to this dot
my control dot value changes dot pipe
start with anything and then map
accepting the value this dot filter out
the options based on the value then we
can define the filter function so
private filter is going to accept a
value of type string and return an array
of strings over here I'm going to have
Const filter value is equal to value dot
to lowercase and then return this dot
options dot filter is going to accept an
option and check if option dot to
lowercase dot includes the filter value
so what is happening here is that
whenever the input value changes this
code right here is called and in the
filter method we accept the filter text
and check if the option includes that
filter text if it does it returns true
and gets displayed if not the option is
hidden in the order complete the final
step is to iterate over this filtered
options in the HTML with the async pipe
so ng for let option of filtered options
with the ACE
pipe
and of course this needs to be just
option if we now take a look at the
browser we should have a working filter
autocomplete
again if it seemed a bit hard to
understand please to make sure you go
through the concepts in angular and then
revisit this video
angular material checkboxes and radio
buttons behave exactly the same as
native checkboxes and radio buttons the
only difference is the styling and
animations that are part of the material
library let's begin with checkboxes the
first step is to import the module same
material module Diaz import Matt
checkbox module and add it to the
material array now we can add a material
checkbox in the HTML the component for a
checkbox is Matt checkbox and the
content between the tags is treated as
the checkbox label if we save this and
take a look at the browser you can see
that we have a checkbox which behaves
exactly like a regular checkbox but this
time we have the addition of styling and
animation by default the label is
positioned to the right of the checkbox
but we can position it to the left using
the label position attribute so back in
the HTML I'm going to duplicate this and
set label position
it's equal to before also going to add a
break tag now save this and take a look
at the browser and you can see that the
label is on the left hand side also if
you can notice by default the theme or
color of check box is the accent color
you can change it to primary or warn
using the color attribute so I'm going
to create two more checkboxes
on the first one I'm going to set color
is equal to primary and on the second
one color is equal to warn now back in
the browser you can see that the first
two checkboxes have an accent team the
third checkbox has a primary team and
the last checkbox has a warranty and
that is all there is to customize the
check box in angular material native
check box with styling and animations
now let's take a look at angular
material radio buttons again
they're basically media radio buttons
with material styling and animations as
always the first step is to import the
module so in material module tortillas
we are going to import mat radio module
and also add it to the material array
now we can add radio buttons in the HTML
there are two main components that we
deal with radio group and radio button
radio buttons are usually placed inside
the radio group component so start off
with matte radio group
and within the radio group we add the
radio buttons Matt radio button I'm
going to make two more copies of this
the first one value is going to be
angular label is angular second one is
react and finally view now if we save
this and take a look at the browser you
can see the three radio buttons angular
react and view again by default the
color of the radio button is set to
accent color of the theme you can change
it using the color attribute for the
first radio button I'm going to add
color is equal to primary and for the
third button color is equal to warn now
if we take a look at the browser the
first one has a primary color the second
one by default has an accent color and
the third one has the warrant color
alright that is pretty much about radio
buttons in angular material now if you
want to access the value of either the
checkbox or the radio buttons you can do
it with two-way binding make sure to
import the forms module and use the
banana in a boxing tags for two-way
binding for a detailed explanation
please go through the angular forms
tutorial on my channel you will find
everything there is to know about form
controls in that series in the next
video let's discuss about the date
picker in angular material
in this video let's take a look at the
date picker component in angular
material to start off in material dot
module dot es we need to import Matt
date picker module and Matt native date
module from angular slash material after
importing add them to the material array
now we can create our first date picker
a Deepika is basically composed of a
text input and a calendar pop-up in the
HTML we are going to start off with a
form field so mat form field and within
the form field component add an input
element with math input attribute
for this input element we are going to
attach an icon which will open the
calendar pop-up the component for the
icon is Matt date picker toggle and we
will add the Matt suffix attribute now
that we have the input and a date picker
toggle we now need the actual date
picker component the component to use is
Matt date picker and now the final step
is to link all the three together on the
date picker create a reference variable
my date picker on the input element add
the Matt date picker property and bind
it with the reference variable my date
picker finally on the date picker toggle
add the fault property and bind to the
reference variable again my date picker
if we now save the files and take a look
at the browser we should have an input
element suffixed with an icon when you
click on the icon a calendar pops up
with today's date selected when you
click on the date the value is saved to
the input element you can also go back
and forth between different months or
also directly jump to a particular year
you can even enter a date in the input
element let's go with April 6th 2019 and
you can see that the date is selected so
this is a basic date picker in angular
material now let's take a look at the
different configurations possible for
this date picker the first one is
regarding the starting view of the
calendar by default it will open the
month view we can change it using the
start view property so on the map date
picker component start view and you can
set this to year in which case it
displays the months of the year for you
can also set it to multi-year
in which case it displays multiple years
another typical requirement when working
with date pickers is setting a minimum
and maximum date that the user can
select we can easily do that with the
min and Max properties going to remove
this start view property and in the
component class I will create two date
objects min date is today's date and Max
date is 2019 3:10 the parameters are
year month and date also please make a
note that the month starts from 0 so we
have the max date set to April 10th 2019
now that we have the min and Max dates
we can bind it to the input component on
the min and Max properties so on an
input element min is going to be equal
to min date and Max is going to be equal
to max date if you now take a look at
the calendar
you should be allowed to select dates
starting from today's date till April
10th you will not be able to select any
other dates now another requirement
sometimes is when you have to filter out
certain dates for example let's say a
user should not be able to pick
Saturdays and Sundays you can do that
while using the Matt day picker filter
property of the date picker input so in
the component class you will need to
create a filter function date filter is
going to accept date and then we are
going to create Const day is equal to
date dot get day to extract just the day
and then we return day is not equal to
zero and day is not equal to six we are
basically preventing Saturdays and
Sundays from being selected now in the
HTML on the input element I'm going to
remove min and Max and said Matt date
picker filter is equal to our function
date filter if we now go back to the
calendar you can see that all the
Saturdays and Sundays are disabled you
can select only the weekdays
all right that is pretty much the basics
of date picker in angular material
let's take a look at tool tips in this
video to get started let's import the
tool tip module so in material module
Diaz import math tool tip module and add
it to the material array next in the
HTML let's create a simple button and
then associate a tooltip with that
button
button the text is going to be hello we
are going to add Matt rais'd
button as an attribute for styling and
then for the tooltip we add Matt tooltip
this is going to be equal to welcome to
code evolution if we save this and take
a look at the browser you can see that
when I hover on the button we get the
tooltip welcome to code evolution and by
default the position of the tool tip is
to the bottom of the element that is
below the element the position can be
controlled using the Matt tooltip
position attribute you can specify
before/after above or below let's go
with Matt tooltip position is equal to
after if you save this and go back to
the browser you can see that the tooltip
is placed after the button element now
if there is no space the tooltip is
placed in the opposite direction for
example if I specify above
in the browser there is no room for the
tooltip to be placed above so the
tooltip is placed below and if I specify
before there is no space to the left so
it would be placed after which is to the
right it is also possible to add delays
for showing and hiding the tooltip
sometimes the user might be just moving
their Mouse around and you don't want
the tooltip to pop up so adding a delay
really helps in those situations we make
use of show delay and hi delay
attributes let's add a two-second delay
Matt tooltip show delay is equal to 2
seconds and Matt tooltip height delay is
equal to 2 seconds now if you go back to
the browser there should be a delay in
the show and height of the tooltip so
hover on the button 1 2 and it shows up
move your mouse away 1 2 and it is
hidden again typically a show delay of
600 milliseconds should be good you
wouldn't really need a high delay but
again it completely depends on your
requirement so that is about tooltips in
angular material let's take a look at
snack bar in the next video
in this video let's take a look at snack
bars and angular material snack bars are
basically like notifications that inform
users of some operation that has been
performed they appear for a short
duration at the bottom of the screen and
they don't require user input to
disappear and at any point in time only
one snack bar notification may be
displayed let's begin by importing the
module so in material dot module dot es
import mat snack bar module and added to
the material array now in our HTML let's
add a button that will open the snack
bar so button add the mat button
attribute and handle the click event on
click we will call a method called
open snack bar passing in a string item
deleted as argument the button text is
going to be show snack bar so we now
have a button that called the open snack
bar method let's go to the class
component and define that method to open
a snack bar we need to make use of a
service and that service is mat snack
bar from angular slash material so go
ahead and import it and once you import
it inject it in the constructor
constructor private snack bar of type
mat snack bar now we can define the open
snack bar method which will actually
open the snack bar so open snack bar
accepts a message and within the body we
use the service instance and call the
open method passing in the message so
the service instance is this dot snack
bar and we call open passing in the
such
if we now save all the files and take a
look at the browser we should have a
button and when I click on the button
the snack bar should pop up at the
bottom of the screen with the message
item deleted so we have a basic snack
bar working as expected
apart from the message we can also
specify an action for a snack bar the
action is specified as the second
argument to the open method on the
service instance to keep the open snack
bar method more generic I will pass the
action parameter as well from the click
handler so in the HTML the second
parameter is going to be the string
dismiss in the component class the
method will now take a second parameter
which is action and the same is passed
to the open method
if you now take a look at the browser
click on the button a snack bar opens
and you can see the message item deleted
and the action dismiss when I click on
this action by default it closes the
snack bar a typical use case for this
type of snack bar is usually to undo an
operation for example let me rename the
button to delete
and the action to undo but when the user
does click on this action we want to
execute some code that will undo the
operation the way we are alerted when
the snack bar is dismissed or the action
is clicked is by using observables so in
the component class we are going to
start off by storing a reference to the
snack bar that has been opened select
snack bar F is equal to this dot snack
bar dot open now using this reference we
can subscribe to the after dismissed or
on action observables so the first one
is after dismissed it's a snack bar
sorry
snack bar F dot after dismissed dot
subscribe and we are going to basically
log the statement the snack bar
was dismissed similarly we also have
snack bar F dot on action dot subscribe
and over here we are going to log the
statement the slack bar action was
triggered if we now go back to the
browser and open dev tools click on the
delete button and click on the action we
can see the log statements in the
console action was clicked and the snack
bar was dismissed I just have console
log statements but you can have the code
to undo the deletion so we have the
message and the action which are passed
to the open method there is also a third
parameter which accepts some
configuration the one which would be
used mostly is the duration property the
Burien property indicates the length of
time in milliseconds to wait before
automatically dismissing the snack bar I
will add an object with the property
duration and set it to 2000 which is two
seconds
say comma and object duration set to two
seconds if you now go back to the
browser click on the button the snack
bar pops up but
after two seconds it automatically
dismisses and in the console you can see
the log statement so the after dismissed
part of the code was executed when the
snack bar was dismissed so when you have
an action you can use the on action
observable and when you don't have an
action but want to execute some code
when the snack bar is dismissed place
that code and the after dismissed
observable the last point to discuss is
about the open from component method as
the name indicates the open from
component method creates and opens a
snag bar with a custom component for the
content let's take a look at an example
in the existing component class which is
AB component dot tias I'm going to
quickly copy paste another component
now you could create the component in a
separate folder but for simplicity I
have it right here as you can see the
template is a span tag with color set to
orange now in the app module I will add
the component in the declarations array
and add to another property called entry
components
all right now that we have a component
to display as custom content let's add a
button and a click handler to open the
snack bar so in the HTML
button mat button click handler is going
to be open custom snag bar the text is
going to be show custom snag bar and in
the component class we're going to
define open custom snack bar and this is
basically going to be this dot snag bar
dot open from component we pass in the
custom component as its first argument
and then we pass in duration of two
seconds if you now go back to the
browser and click on show custom snack
bar we should have our orange colored
notification custom snack bar
alright guys in this video we are going
to take a look at dialogues in angular
material a dialogue is a type of modal
window that appears in front of the app
content to provide information or ask
for information the usage of a dialog is
very similar to that of the snack bar
component we looked at in the last video
so this video should be pretty
straightforward if you've understood how
a snack bar works alright let's get
started first step import mat dialogue
module
and add it to the material array next in
the HTML create a button that can open
the dialogue so button add the attribute
mat rais'd button add a click handler
which is open dialogue and then the
button text is going to be open dialogue
now let's define the open dialogue
method
to be able to actually open the dialogue
we need the Matt dialog service so
import Matt dialog from angular slash
material after importing we need to
inject it
so constructor let's go with public
dialog of type Matt dialog and then we
can define the open dialogue method
within the body we are going to have
this dot dialogue dot open and the open
method on dialogue accepts two
parameters the first parameter is a
component and the second parameter is
optional configuration to pass in a
component parameter let's first create
it so in the terminal we use angular CLI
and run the command ng G for generate C
for component and the name of the
component which is going to be dialogue
- example and I'm also going to skip the
test files the command creates a folder
for the component and adds it to the app
module but a component that is used for
a dialogue also has to be included in
the entry components array so over here
dialog example component now we can pass
this component as our parameter so nav
dot component es this dot dialogue dot
open and the first parameter is going to
be dialog example component
all right let's go back to the browser
and test this out if I click on the
button a dialog pops up with the content
dialog example works and this is the
HTML corresponding to our dialog example
component right now we just have a
paragraph tag but there are several
directives meant specifically to
structure the dialogue content let's use
them instead so envious code I'm going
to open the file dialog example dot HTML
and first we specify a dialogue title
using the mat dialogue title directive
so I'm going to add an h2 tag and the
directive is going to be mad dialogue
title this is going to be session
timeout next for the content we have
Matt dialogue content so this is going
to be Matt dialogue content and the text
is going to be you will be logged out
due to inactivity next for the dialogue
action we have the Matt dialogue actions
let's create two buttons one to stay
signed in and want to log out so keep me
logged in or log out now on both these
buttons if you want the click event to
close the dialogue we need to add the
Matt dialogue close directive so on both
the buttons Matt dialogue close
alright let's test this out if you go
back to the browser and I click on the
button we have the model with the title
content and the buttons when I click the
button it closes the dialogue as well
and we have two buttons intended for
different purposes how would we know
whether to log the user out or keep them
signed in when the dialog closes on the
button click we can do that using the
after closed observable which
conveniently returns a result
so back in vs code in the component
class first create a reference to the
dialog so let dialogue ref is going to
be this dot dialogue dot open now we can
subscribe to the observable dialogue ref
dot after closed dot subscribe we get a
result and let's simply log that to the
console dialog result is result finally
we assign a value to the mat dialogue
closed directive which is accessed as
the result so in the HTML for the
dialogue on keep me logged in button mat
dialogue close is going to be equal to
true for the first case and false for
logout let's go back to the browser and
test this out I'm going to open the
console click on open dialogue and click
on keep me logged in you can see that it
says dialogue result true and click on
logout it says dialogue result false
so in the subscription method you can
have the code that checks for the result
if result is equal to true keep them
signed in and if result is equal to
false love them out the final point to
discuss with dialogues is passing in the
data to the dialogue component and there
are a couple of steps so let's go over
each of them the first step specify the
data as the second parameter to the
dialogue open method so this is going to
be an object the key is going to be data
which in turn is going to be an object
I'm going to pass a name called vishwas
so this is the second argument to the
open method next open the component
class for the dialogue example component
so dialogue example component dot TS to
access the data in the dialogue
component we have to use the mat
dialogue data injection token so first
import inject from angular slash core
next import mat dialogue data from
angular slash material and then we
inject it in the constructor so
constructor is going to be at inject and
we are injecting mat dialogue data and
then we say public data of type any so
basically we are now making the dialogue
component capable of receiving any type
of data now in the dialogue component
HTML we can simply interpolate the data
object so in math dialogue content I'm
going to add high data dot name if you
now go back to the browser and click on
open dialogue you can see that content
says Huayra choise you will be logged
out due to inactivity so we are able to
pass data to the dialogue component
now if you want to specify height and
width for the dialogue it can be passed
into the configuration object there are
a bunch of properties you can use based
on your requirement so I'll leave that
for you guys to explore browse the API
tab in the documentation and you will
find everything you need alright I hope
you now have a good understanding of how
to work with dialogues in angular
material
all right in this video let's take a
look at implementing a basic data table
in angular material the first step as
always is to import the module so in
material dot module dot es import math
table module and added to the material
array
now what we are going to do to save us
some time is copy the code for a basic
data table and then understand the
different parts that are responsible for
the functioning of a data table so in
the material Doc's go to components and
then to the data table section and click
on the table link over here in the
examples tab we have a basic data table
now go to the second example which is
basic use of math table and uses display
flex and click on the code icon now
let's copy paste the code first the HTML
so copy and paste it an AB component dot
HTML next the typescript file so go to
TS copy the interface and the data in AB
component TS paste it right after the
import statement then go back to the
documentation and copy the two lines of
code from the component class go back to
BS code and in app component paste them
finally copy the CSS so over here CSS
and then copy this and paste it in AB
component dot CSS now if we save all the
files and take a look at the browser you
should be able to see a data table now
let's understand the different parts
that make up this data table the first
part to implementing a data table is the
data source every data table needs a
data source that contains the data to be
displayed in our example we have the
data of periodic elements we have an
interface that defines the type of
each element so a periodic element will
have a name position weight and symbol
right below the interface is where you
see the array of periodic elements we
have ten elements each having properties
mentioned in the interface what you have
to notice here is that the interface and
the data array is declared outside the
component to be able to use it in the
component we need to create a property
and initialize it for that purpose we
have data source which is initialized to
element data this array right here
alright the next thing to do is to
provide this data source to the data
table and we do that in the HTML so an
app dot component dot HTML we create a
data table with mat table component and
to provide the data source we make use
of the data source attribute we use
property binding to bind the property
defined in the component class so data
source is equal to element data which is
provided here so that is the first step
to implementing a data table creating
the data source and binding it to the
table the second step is to define the
column templates in the browser you can
see that we have four columns the
position number name weight and symbol
in the code we define the four columns
each inside its own NG container element
physician named weight and symbol the ng
container element will not be rendered
to the Dom but it will provide an
element for applying this mat column
death directive the mat column death
directive is what uniquely identifies a
given column with a key position name we
and symbol inside the ng container
element we will have all the
configuration for a given column you can
see that we have the template that
defines how to display the header for a
given column identified using the map
header cell death structural directive
we also have another template that
defines how to display the data cells of
a given column using the mat cell def
structural directive the to structural
directives do not attach any styling to
the elements the styling is taken care
of by mat header cell and mat cell
components next let's talk about the
content of the heading and the data
cells for the heading you can see that
we just have static text number name
weight and symbol but for the data cell
we get access to each row of the data
source we obtain a reference to each row
and then access the different properties
of each row we then use interpolation to
bind the data to the view so in our data
source we have ten rows we iterate
through the rows get a reference to each
row and store it in the element variable
and then we access the appropriate
property in the column template so
element dot position dot name dot weight
in dot symbol these are the different
properties for each element
all right now what we have done so far
is just define the column template how
it's supposed to look the final step is
to define the rows in the data table and
for that we make use of two more
components to define the table header
row we make use of the mat header row
component and to determine which columns
have to be displayed in the table mat
header row death structural directive is
used to this we assign displayed columns
property which is an array of columns we
have mentioned in the component class so
display columns is an array of strings
with positioned name weight and symbol
similarly to display the data rows we
make use of the mat row component now
with math burrow death structural
directive we also have a variable
exported that we have named as row
containing the data of that given row
and we have to specify the columns
property which contains the order in
which the data cells should be rendered
again this is displayed columns property
so when you run this code we should have
the data table working as expected
position name weight and symbol and then
the different rows corresponding to each
entry or each item and the element array
so to summarize there are three steps in
implementing a data table in angular
material first up define the data source
and the columns to be displayed
second step define the column templates
and finally the third step include the
header and the row definitions so we are
able to create a very basic data table
we copy pasted the code and did not
really code anything as such so in the
next video let's also try to make some
changes and see how that impacts the
data table that will give you guys a
much better idea of how the data table
works
in this video let's take a more detailed
look at data tables in angular material
let's start with the displayed columns
property this property as the name
suggests controls the columns to be
displayed in the browser as you can see
it is just an array of strings if I were
to for example remove symbol from this
list
take a look at the browser the column is
not displayed so the property controls
which of the columns have to be shown
but there is more to it than just
showing and hiding of columns the order
in which you specify the fields to be
displayed is the order in which the
columns are displayed in the browser you
can see that we have the order as
position name weight and symbol and in
the browser the columns are in the exact
same order physician name weight and
symbol if you want the weight column to
be the last column you just have to
specify the weight column as the last
column in displayed columns property so
I'm going to cut this out
and paste it after symbol if I now go
back to the browser
weight is displayed as the last column
which now brings me to the HTML to
highlight another point the order in
which you specify these column templates
with the ng container tag doesn't affect
the order in any way whatsoever the
order is controlled by the displayed
columns property which is specified to
the mat header row and mat row
components but orders matter with the
container column template is the mat
column definition attribute the value
has to be a value from the displayed
columns property if I've already changed
position to let's say position test same
and take a look at the browser you can
see that the code breaks and the data
table is not displayed so make sure you
specify the right column name to the
template next let's talk about the mat
row component you can see that we have
two variables declared row and columns
the columns property is set to displayed
columns to indicate what data has to be
displayed let's change this and see what
happens so in the class component I'm
going to create another property called
displayed columns data and in this list
I'm going to remove weight also back in
the HTML I'm going to set columns to
display columns data if you now take a
look at the browser you can see that we
have only three columns of data being
displayed and four columns of header the
data for the weight column is hidden so
it is very much possible to set separate
columns to be displayed for the header
and the data but then again not sure if
you would ever want to do that next
let's talk about the road
raishin what this helps us with is to
get hold of the raw data to handle
events on each row in the data table for
example I can add a click event binding
and call a method that provides us with
the raw data let's call this log data
and pass in that row variable now in the
component class we can quickly define
log data accepts a row and let's just
console.log it if I save the files and
take a look at the browser open console
and click on a row you can see the
corresponding row data being logged in
the console so if you have any action
that has to be performed for example
editing deleting or navigating to a
different route pasted on this row data
this is the way to go
fasten the data extract the ID probably
of that column and perform the necessary
action all right then I hope that now
you have a much better understanding of
how a data table works in angular
material next let's take a look at
filtering sorting and pagination in data
tables
features like filtering salting and
pagination have been made really simple
in angular material let's take a look at
filtering in this video sorting and
pagination in subsequent videos
filtering can be achieved in three
simple steps the first step is to create
a data source as an instance of the mat
table data source class so let's begin
by importing mat table data source from
angular material next we create a data
source property as an instance of this
imported class so data source is going
to be new mat table data source and then
we pass in element data as the argument
so that is our first step creating the
data source as an instance of the mat
table data source class second step is
to create an input field where the user
can enter the filter text let's add that
code in the HTML mat form field then an
input element we add the mat input
attribute and also a placeholder that
says filter every time the user enters
some text we need to filter the data
table for that we listen to the key up
event
so key up and on key up we are going to
call a method called apply filter and to
this method we pass in the filter text
which is accessed using dollar event dot
target dot value that is the second step
creating a filter input the final step
is to define this apply filter method
which actually filters the data source
so back in the component class apply
filter accepts the filtered text of type
string and within the method all we have
to do is assign the filter text value to
the filter property of the data source
so this dot data source dot filter is
equal to filter value dot trim dot to
lowercase now this kind of seems like
magic but let me tell you how it works
remember the math table data source
class that we imported well that class
has a property called filter when you
want to filter out the data all you have
to do is assign a string to that
property when you assign the filter
value the data source will reduce each
row to a serialized form and will filter
out the row if it does not contain that
filtered value or to put it in simpler
terms does the data rope contain the
filter if yes only then display the row
so if we take a look at the browser you
can see that we have a filter input I
type H and you can see it filters the
elements type H E and it filters further
I can also filter on numeric values type
6 and you can see it filters out the
rows that don't contain the number 6 so
three basic steps for filtering creating
the data source as an
instance of math table datasource
creating the input filter and finally on
cube of that input element assign the
filter value to the filter property of
the data source alright in the next
video let's take a look at sorting in
data tables
in this video let's take a look at
sorting in data tables just like
filtering angular material makes it
really simple to implement the sorting
feature for your data table now there
are three simple steps the first step is
to import the material sorting module so
in material dot module tortillas we are
going to import matte salt module and
add it to the material array
second step we need to add directives to
the material table in the HTML so on the
mat table itself we need to add the mat
salt directive and to each column header
cell that should trigger sorting we need
to add the mat sort header directive
let's add it to the first three columns
so on mat header cell mat sort header
and I'm going to add it to the next two
columns as well so on mat header cell
mat sort header and the same again the
final step is to provide the mats our
directive to the datasource so in the
types of file import mat sort from
angular slash material next we use the
view child decorator to get hold of a
reference to the mat sort component so
first import view child from angular
slash core and then in the component
class at view child mat sort sort of
type mat salt and finally in the ng on
init method we assigned the mat sort
component to the sort property of the
data table so import on in it from
angular slash core app component
implements on in it and then we define
ng on in it this dot datasource dot sort
is equal to this dot sort and that is
pretty much it let's save the files and
take a look at the browser now when I
hover on the column header you can see
an arrow mark when I click on the header
the elements are sorted in ascending
order click on the header again the
elements are sorted in descending order
click again and the sorting is removed
similarly you can also saw
on name and weight ascending descending
and no salt the symbol column on the
other hand is not sortable that is
because we did not attach the Matt salt
header directive to this column so there
you go
sorting data table in three simple steps
include the Matt sort module add the
directives in the HTML mats or header
and Matt sword and finally assign the
Matt sort component to the sword
probability of the data source in the
next video let's take a look at
pagination
in this video let's take a look at
pagination in data tables similarity
sorting pagination can be implemented in
three simple steps the first step is to
import the material Pigeon ater module
so in material module Diaz import map
pigeon ater module and add it to the
material array second step we add the
paginated component in the HTML so after
Matt table map pigeon ater and we are
going to specify two options to the page
inator the first one is the page size we
specify that using the page size options
property
let's go with 5 10 and 20 the second
option is to show the first and last
buttons of the page inator show first
last buttons and we simply include it as
an attribute the final step is to
provide the map paginated directive to
the data source so in the types of file
import mat pigeon eighter from angular
slash material and then use the view
child decorator to get hold of a
reference to the map page inator
component add view child mat regginator
the variable is going to be pigeon ATAR
of type map page inator finally in the
ng on init method we assign the mat
paginated component to the paginated
property of the datasource so this dot
datasource dot originator is equal to
this dot page inator and that is it
let's save the files and take a look at
the browser at first glance you can see
that the styling is sort of broken so
let's fix that in the HTML we are going
to wrap the table
as well as pigeon eater in a div tag and
then we are going to move this elevation
class from math table to the div tag now
if you go back to the browser you can
see that it looks much better by default
five items are displayed per page you
can change it to ten or even twenty you
can also go back and forth between the
pages using the icon buttons the first
page and last page buttons might not be
necessary for small data sets but if you
have several hundreds of rows with a
small page size you can definitely
include the show first and last buttons
attribute
welcome back everyone in this video
let's take a look at virtual scrolling
with angular cdk sometimes you might
have to display hundreds or thousands of
elements which can be slow in any
browser virtual scrolling will help you
in such situations with virtual
scrolling you can display large lists of
elements performant ly by only rendering
the items that fit on the screen let's
see how that can be done in this video
the first step we need to import the
scrolling module from angular cdk so in
AB dot module dot es import scrolling
module from angular slash CD k slash
scrolling next add it to the imports
array so scrolling module added to the
imports array now for the second step we
are going to create an array of a
thousand numbers so in the component
class which is AB dot component or TS
file I'm going to create a new property
numbers which is going to be an array
then in the constructor for that I
equals 0 I less than thousand I plus
plus this dot numbers dot push I all
right
now that we have a huge list of numbers
let's render them in the HTML I will
first render them with the ng4 directive
and then show you how it works with
virtual scrolling then the HTML add a
div tag and then add the mg4 directive
and v4 is equal to let number of numbers
and then we simply render the number I'm
also going to add a bit of styling to
this div tag so open up and add a class
called number with display flex justify
content center-aligned
items center let's go with a border to
pixels solid maroon and then box-sizing
border box and back in the HTML I'm
going to add the class number alright if
we now save the file and take a look at
the browser you should be able to see
all the list of numbers what I want to
focus on though is the Dom itself if I
open dev tools you can see that all of
the thousand elements are present in the
Dom tree so this is the list with ng for
directive now let's implement the list
with virtual scrolling back in the HTML
the first thing we have to do is create
a viewport for the virtual scroll the
component is cdk virtual scroll view
port on this viewport we have to define
the item size attribute and this is
basically an indication of the size of
each element I have specified item size
as 100 so in the number class as well
let's add height is equal to hundred
next we need to specify a height for the
viewport itself and for that I'm going
to create a CSS class this is going to
be called container and I'm going to set
the height property to 400 pixels and
back in the HTML on the viewport plus is
equal to container now each element is a
hundred pixels tall and the viewport is
400 pixels tall so we should be able to
see four elements at any given time back
in the HTML I'm going to move this div
tag within the viewport now for the
actual list of numbers we do the same as
what we did before with ng for the only
difference now is that we are going to
use
cdk virtual fault instead of ng4 so CDK
virtual for this is the directive you
have to make use of inside a virtual
scrolling container and that is pretty
much it
if you now save the files and go back to
the browser we should only be seen four
elements at a time and as we scroll down
we can see the rest of the elements but
what is important though is observing
the Dom tree you can see that instead of
rendering all the thousand elements we
are now rendering only a handful of them
as you scroll the Dom nodes update to
reflect the numbers being displayed so
this way we can implement a more
performant list to display items all
right with that we come to the end of
this angular material series I hope you
are now in a better position to start
using some of the material components in
your own projects